merci d'être avec nous Agnès canadienne
de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure aider de la
Seine-Maritime apparentée au groupe les
républicains vice-président de la
délégation sénatoriale au collectivité
territoriales et à la décentralisation
on va bien sûr longuement parler du
Congrès des mers des finances des
collectivités mais d'abord un mot sur ce
débat entre les trois candidats on en a
vu les temps forts hier un seul débat
entre les trois candidats à la
présidence des républicains qu'est-ce
que vous en avez pensé c'est un débat de
bonne tenue selon vous oui effectivement
ce débat c'est plutôt bien déroulé je
pense que chacun a pu exprimer
clairement ses idées moi j'ai toujours
une question de fond c'est quelle
nécessité de faire un débat comme ça sur
une chaîne publique qui concerne
l'organisation interne d'un parti
politique je pense que c'est débat il
intéresse avant tous les militants
puisque seul eux peuvent désigner le
futur président du parti voilà
divergences comme ça sur la place
publique parce qu'il y a quand même eu
des divergences de ligne entre les trois
candidats bien sûr c'est plutôt simple
plutôt sain qui est des divergences je
pense qu'un pari un parti n'a pas
intérêt à être mon il faut véritablement
que puisse s'exprimer différentes
sensibilités dès lors qu'on est d'accord
sur la sur la base sur le fond des
fondement sur les valeurs maintenant
effectivement de faire je pense que
avant tout cela aurait dû se dérouler
devant les militants et je pense que ça
a pas intéressé nombre de Français vous
ne voterez pas puisque vous avez quitté
les républicains si vous deviez voter
vous voteriez pour qui bon écoutez je ne
vote pas donc je vais pas vous dire mais
c'est vrai que j'ai plutôt un candidat
de coeur c'est celui que je connais le
plus et avec qui je travaille le plus au
quotidien
on imagine il y a eu des divergences sur
les retraites sur la question de l'IVG
sur la question des éoliennes on a vu
sur ce vote au Sénat est-ce qu'après ça
le rassemblement vous semble encore
possible
oui parce que je vous disais dans un
parti on peut avoir des dissensions
effectivement sur la question de l'IVG
sur la question des éoliennes on voit
que la position du Sénat c'est souvent
une position qui est empreinte à la fois
de bon sens qui est moins sous la
pression politique qui correspond plus
généralement à des arguments soit
juridiques soit technique soit
d'applications je disais pragmatique
donc voilà on a une vision qui souvent
ou parfois diverses de celles notamment
des députés qui sont plus enclins à la
pression politique vous êtes proche
d'Edouard Philippe vous êtes concernant
municipal dans sa ville du Havre on a vu
hier trois lignes de droite de droite
affirmée est-ce que c'est une situation
qui peut profiter à Édouard Philippe
écoutez je ne sais pas Édouard Philippe
s'affirme aussi et est un homme de
droite donc c'est vrai que il y a un
certain nombre de sujets
bien évidemment parce qu'on a vu quand
même que et c'est un peu la difficulté
de cet exercice et qu'on a une tendance
à la droiteisation et attirer très à
droite c'est pour ça que moi je ne suis
plus dans le parti de la républicains
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus ma
ligne en revendiquant très clairement
d'être une femme de droite Édouard
Philippe il y a des sujets sur lesquels
il est d'accord voir il va plus loin je
pense notamment à la question des
retraites
après il y a d'autres sujets sur
lesquels manifestement ce n'est pas sa
ligne c'est très clairement pas sa ligne
donc il y a des espaces qui sont bien
différents il sera au Congrès des mers
aujourd'hui on va en parler Édouard
Philippe il sera seulement en tant que
mère du Havre ou un peu pour préparer le
terrain avec les élus locaux en vue 2017
2027 il sera évidemment en tant
qu'Edouard Philippe en tant que merdura
parce qu'il a une vraie connaissance du
terrain une vraie légitimité left une
ville qui bouge qui un projet qui met en
place énormément d'actions et c'est
particulièrement en tant que mère du
Havre que c'est que gérer une
collectivité locale après il est ancien
Premier ministre un président de parti
et qu'en tant probable futur candidat à
la présidentielle il est président de
parti il est ancien Premier ministre
c'est un homme et un seul homme donc il
va en tant que tel Emmanuel Macron
tronche en tout cas devant les maires
ils se rendra au salon des mers
c'est-à-dire juste à côté du Congrès
est-ce que vous regrettez cette absence
de discours d'Emmanuel Macron ça
étonnant alors je sais pas je pense ça
fait partie de ces nouvelles méthodes
aujourd'hui pour faire de la politique
je pense que un président de la
République incarné incarner une
politique et doit expliquer sa politique
et que son rôle c'est de la présenter il
a là une tribune avec le Congrès des
mers idéal mais je pense que c'est un
exercice dans lequel il est absolument
pas à l'aise et que il préfère aller
directement sur le terrain alors je sais
pas très bien ce que ça va montrer je
suis pas sûr qu'il verra au temps de mer
que ça dans les allées du Palais des
Congrès je trouve effectivement cette
méthode un peu étonnante David Lisnard
le président de l'Association des maires
de France demande une grande loi de
décentralisation est-ce que vous
soutenez cette demande oui je pense que
aujourd'hui on a besoin de redonner du
souffle de redonner du souffle aux
initiatives locales on voit aujourd'hui
Gérard Larcher le défend depuis de
nombreuses années le Sénat a fait de
nombreuses les fameux 50 propositions il
y a un groupe décentralisation qui
travaille encore sur ces questions-là
pour approfondir le sujet on a besoin
d'un nouveau souffle on a besoin de
redonner de l'espace on voit que les
mers sont trop soumis à la contrainte à
la norme à la règle à des politiques qui
sont très descendantes je pense que ce
cette nouvelle loi décentralisation elle
est essentielle et elle ne pourra pas se
faire sans plus de déconcentration aussi
aujourd'hui plus l'initiatives locales
même au sein des préfectures et des
sous-préfectures il y a une question qui
inquiète les mères on va parler de la
question des finances dans quelques
instants mais c'est la question de la
sécurité il y a une enquête du sevy-pov
pour le monde qui montre que 63% des
élus déclarent avoir été victime d'actes
d'incivilité c'était
53%, il y a quelques mois est-ce que
vous demandez plus de sanctions par les
agresseurs des lieux
plus de sanctions mais surtout plus de
réactivité effectivement cela augmente
c'est lié aussi au désengagement et des
citoyens vis-à-vis de la puissance
publique l'absence théisme lors des
élections tout ce fossés qui se créent
moi je pense qu'une des réponses mais
elle est pas elle est pas propre aux
élus mais elle est particulièrement
vraie pour les élus qui en dose des
responsabilités c'est que la justice
soit réactive c'est que la justice
prononce des peines sévères qu'elles le
fasse savoir et qu'elle informe les
mères surtout des suites qui sont
données donc le problème c'est pas la
loi c'est leur exécution c'est son
exécution je pense que le problème c'est
avant tout l'exécution aujourd'hui avec
toutes les difficultés qu'on compte le
monde judiciaire des mères qui sont
inquiets pour leur marge de manoeuvre
évidemment les finances de leur commune
ils en appellent au Sénat qui poursuit
l'examen du budget on va voir les temps
forts de ces dernières heures de séances
avec Alex Moussa
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Agnès bonjour
Alex on va bien sur parler des finances
des collectivités il en a été question
ces dernières heures au Sénat mais
d'abord le Sénat a rendu hommage à
l'agent des finances publiques qui a été
tué lors d'un contrôle fiscal dans le
Pas-de-Calais le ministre en charge des
comptes publics l'annoncés hier soir au
sénateur il a interrompu les débats pour
évoquer ce drame
vous me permettrez de dire que ce soit
le service public il a le visage de ce
chef de brigade tué alors qu'il
accomplissait sa mission sa passion au
service du bien commun et donc
l'hémicycle du Sénat observés hier un
moment de recueillement en la mémoire de
cet agent Agnès canailler ce drame
est-ce que c'est l'illustration une
nouvelle fois des violences qui
augmentent contre les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique oui
ça va de pair avec le sujet précédent
d'abord je voudrais avoir une pensée
évidemment pour cet agent de la fonction
publique et pour sa famille endeuillée
dans cette accident est terrible oui
c'est vrai que on voit aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y a plus de barrière et que même quand
on est représentant de l'État en mission
de service public il n'y a pas de
respect plus comme ceux qui ont en doses
des responsabilités politiques je trouve
que aujourd'hui c'est une dérive de
notre société malheureusement
on parlait de la question des finances
publiques des inquiétudes des élus
locaux il en a été question hier lors du
débat budgétaire Alex avec un point de
tension c'est la suppression de la CVAE
qui est souhaitée par le gouvernement
d'abord qu'est-ce que la célèbre alors
la CVE c'est la cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises c'est un impôt
sur les entreprises qui est perçu par
les collectivités notamment les
départements et les intercommunalités un
impôt qui leur rapporte 8 milliards
d'euros chaque année et pour renforcer
la compétitivité des entreprises et bien
le gouvernement souhaite supprimer cet
impôt alors ça fait une perte fiscale
pour les collectivités qui sera
compensée par une fraction de TVA
annonce le gouvernement mais beaucoup de
sénateurs notamment à gauche sont contre
la suppression de cette impôt écoutez
Patrick canaire le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat il n'est pas
question pour nous monsieur le ministre
en tant que groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain que nous acceptions que
l'impôt payé par des entreprises soit
transférées finalement à tous les
Français qui devront contribuer au
travers de la TVA au financement des
territoriale donc c'est une situation
qui est totalement injuste alors dans ce
débat les sénateurs les républicains de
la majorité sénatoriale souhaitait
reporter d'un an en 2024 la suppression
de cette impôt sur les entreprises mais
au final coup de théâtre dans ce débat
puisque une majorité de sénateurs de
gauche alliés à des sénateurs centristes
ont carrément annulé à la suppression de
la CVAE la cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises elle est
sénateurs les républicains qui
d'habitude sont majoritaires au Sénat
avec leurs alliés centrist et bien ils
sont ils se sont trouvés en minorité
alors on le rappelle un gouvernement
pourra revenir sur cette annulation pour
rétablir sa réforme à la surveille
nationale notamment en utilisant le 49-3
Agnès canailler le fait que le Sénat
annule la suppression de cette impôt sur
les entreprises c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'économie
oui je pense que c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle nous sommes moi je suis
particulièrement favorable et mon groupe
aussi elle a suppression des impôts de
production qui grève la compétitivité
des entreprises françaises on l'a vu
notamment et on le voit particulièrement
dans le contexte économique difficile
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est un mauvais signe
néanmoins on voit bien que cette réforme
de la CVAE elle est pas tout à fait
affinée elle est pas tout à fait prête
parce que évidemment c'est impose une
compensation une compensation pour être
sûr que les collectivités territoriales
bénéficient des mêmes ressources et
aujourd'hui le dispositif de
compensation via une part de la TVA
n'est pas tout à fait claire et c'est
cela que pointe les sénateurs aurait
préféré le report d'un an pour pouvoir
avoir le temps de vraiment préparer
cette réforme et éviter un peu les
secousses qu'on avait eu avec la taxe
d'habitation pour ce qui concerne cette
réforme de la CVAE que nous appelons
quand même de nos vœux justement est-ce
que vous diriez que les réformes de
fiscalité locale du gouvernement à
savoir vous le disiez la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation dans le premier
quinquennat de la suppression de cette
impôts de production est-ce que ça
fragilise les finances de nos élus
locaux des collectivités territoriales
sa fragilise au sens pas tellement en
tant que montant parce que l'État s'est
engagé à chaque fois assurer une
compensation à l'euro près même si on
sait toujours que c'est compensations
elles sont valables les premières années
qu'on a pas de visibilité au fil du
temps mais ça crée quand même une
difficulté majeure pour aujourd'hui qui
est relative à l'autonomie des
collectivités locales puisque les
collectivités locales du coup n'ont plus
la main sur la détermination du montant
de l'impôt elle dépend de la volonté de
l'État on parlait tout à l'heure de la
nécessité d'avoir un nouveau choc de
décentralisation qui me paraît
aujourd'hui essentiel pour renforcer
cette autonomie des collectivités
locales donner plus de place à
l'initiative ça passe avant tout par la
maîtrise et l'autonomie financière la
question aussi c'est les divergences
parce que là ce qui s'est passé c'est
que c'est les centrist qui ont mis les
républicains en minorité en disant mais
nous on est du côté des collectivités
comment vous réagissez à ça
oui alors effectivement mais la majorité
au Sénat elle n'est pas composée
uniquement des républicains et
l'addition de deux groupes qui ont des
sensibilités différentes dans ce dossier
de la CVAE c'est vrai qu'il y a deux
intérêts en balance celui des
entreprises et celui des collectivités
locales comme toujours ça dépend de quel
côté on fait penser la balance et
aujourd'hui c'est pas très clair nous on
préférait reporter d'un an pour affiner
et permettre d'y voir clair les Centris
sont préférées eux verrouillés et
refuser ce reports et cette agression de
la céréale sur la hausse des prix de
l'énergie parce que ça aussi c'est une
inquiétude évidemment des mères et des
élus locaux alors le gouvernement promet
un amortisseur électricité est-ce que
c'est suffisant pour vous
non c'est vrai que c'est essentiel déjà
parce que les collectivités locales vont
subir comme tous les Français se coulent
l'énergie
77% des élus se disputent par là
effectivement notamment pour les petites
collectivités locales qui ont des
budgets sur lesquels il n'y a pas de
marge de manœuvre quand vous avez des
marges de manœuvre vous pouvez reporter
un investissement faire plus de sobriété
etc quand vous avez des petits budgets
donc des peu d’équipements vous n'avez
pas beaucoup de marge de manœuvre donc
on voit bien que la facture elle va être
terrible et elle va peser directement
sur les budgets aujourd'hui il y a
différentes mesures notamment le fameux
filet de sécurité mais là aussi on y
voit pas très clair on a eu le filet de
sécurité dans le PLF mais qui a été sous
taillée ou mal taillée on nous disait
aujourd'hui que ça devait
tous ces 22 000 communes au final ce
n'est plus que 9000 communes dans le
projet de loi de finances on a essayé le
gouvernement est-ce qu'il y a une
modifier mais aujourd'hui rien n'est
encore extrêmement clair c'est qui vont
être forts au Sénat parce qu'on a
vraiment besoin de visibilité les
communes et après de clarification il y
a un besoin il y a un problème vraiment
de clarification et les mères ont besoin
d'être rassurés pour engager des projets
faut savoir où vous allez faut savoir
les les finances vous avez besoin parce
que je rappelle quand même que les
finances locales qui représentent 75 %
de l'investissement public elles sont
obligées d'avoir un budget à l'équilibre
et pas le cas de l'État donc les maires
pour engager les dépenses doivent savoir
où ils vont donc il y a besoin de
clarification
important hier au Sénat c'est la baisse
de la TVA sur les transports en commun
mais oui le Sénat baissé de 10% à 5,5%
la TVA sur tous les transports en commun
sauf les TGV qui sont mises en
concurrence une baisse de TVA qui va
profiter à la fois aux usagers pour
faire face à la hausse des prix du train
qui s'annonce mais également aux
collectivités locales notamment les
régions qui sont autorités
organisatrices de transport cette
proposition de baisser la TVA sur le
transport en commun elle vient de la
droite et du sénateur Philippe Tabaro
il nous agissons pas rapidement l'offre
de transport en commun dans notre pays
va chuter brutalement et les tarifs vont
exploser pour les usagers nous serons
ainsi à contre-courant face aux enjeux
climatiques qui nous attendent et puis
dans ce débat sur la fiscalité
écologique des transports à la gauche et
quelques sénateurs centrist là encore
souhaité taxer les jets privés et les
yachts une mauvaise idée pour le
ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attala moi je préfère qu'on dépense de
l'argent pour investir dans l'avion va
carbone dans des navires qui polluent
moins même avec des amendements ou avec
lesquels j'étais pas totalement en
accord tout à l'heure plutôt que de
créer des taxes à faiblement ou c'est
super on va recruter plein de
fonctionnaires pour des taxes qui
rapporteront pas grand chose pour les
calculer et les recouvrer qui ne
changeront absolument rien en pratique
que vous évoquez au final une majorité
de sénateurs autour des sénateurs les
républicains ont réussi à rejeter cette
idée d'une taxe sur les yachts et elle
est jet privé
le Sénat ce weekend c'est sur les super
confiant oui ce weekend en amendement
dans ce débat au Sénat prévoyait une
taxe de 33% sur les super profits des
entreprises c'est à dire sur les
bénéfices supérieur à 10 millions
d'euros une mesure défendue par la
gauche mais là encore une mesure
défendue par les sénateurs centristes et
côté le président du groupe centriste au
Sénat Hervé Marseille premier il est
politique problème il est politique
est-ce que on considère qui a des
profits exceptionnels à un moment donné
oui puisque on les taxe même au niveau
européen donc qui soit nationaux ou
européen c'est qu'on les reconnaît mais
on préfère se planquer derrière les
Allemands derrière les autres qui eux
qui eux dès le mois de juillet ont
organisé des contributions nationales
les Espagnols les Italiens de Monsieur
Draghi Boris Johnson en Angleterre à ma
connaissance c'est pas des marxistes les
ninistes la majorité du Sénat encore
divisée sur cette question mais au final
sur la taxe sur les super profits c'est
ce sont les républicains qui ont le
dernier mot puisque une majorité de
sénateurs s'est opposé à cette taxe tout
comme le gouvernement qui défend une
contribution européenne sur les super
profils contribution européenne qui
devraient rapporter 11 milliards d'euros
selon Gabriel Attal Agnès canaillé les
centriste les sénateurs de gauche
étaient pour cette taxe nationale sur
les super profits ça peut être quand
même une mesure de justice en ce moment
oui mais il faut toujours regarder aussi
entre le symbole et Hervé Marcel là
clairement dit que c'était une position
symbolique et les effets réels les
effets réels sur ces super profits moi
je suis plutôt favorable non pas une
taxation mais à qu'on mette en place des
pressions sur les entreprises qui font
des bénéfices record pour qu'il y ait de
réinvestissement c'est ce qui s'est fait
avec la CMA CGM je connais
particulièrement bien waouh sur une zone
portuaire qui a réinvesti rodolsaad
s'est engagé pour réinvestir dans
l'investissement pour avoir des navires
plus propres
idem chez Total je pense que c'est une
meilleure solution d'autant plus que ce
sujet est un sujet européen je pense que
les enjeux sont aussi de la solidarité
européenne sur ces questions là donc
vous privilégiez la solution européenne
alors pour faire bouger certains
comportements notamment en termes de
transport pourquoi ne pas taxer les jet
et les yachts privés
est-ce que je pense que là aussi c'est
du symbole je pense qu'on n'est pas là
pour légiférer sur le symbole
ce qui ferait plaisir et qu'en verrez un
coup de choix sur sur des mesures je
pense que ce qui importe c'est d'avoir
des des mesures de fond et comme la dit
je pense cette fois-ci avec justesse le
ministre c'est que ça coûterait beaucoup
plus cher parce que ça il faut recourir
ces impôts là c'est pas simplement une
loi et des dispositions derrière c'est
d'applications c'est des fonctionnaires
c'est des moyens et je pense qu'on a
d'autres mesures beaucoup plus
intéressantes à mettre en place
notamment des mesures de sobriété et des
mesures qui vont favoriser le recours
aux transports publics et comme c'est le
cas notamment avec la baisse de la TVA
que une bonne mesure justement cette
baisse de la TVA sur le transport en
commun ça va faire du bien aux usagers
et aux collectivités qui pilotent ces
transports oui tout à fait je pense que
c'est une bonne mesure c'est une mesure
qui va dans le sens de la massification
des transports et des déplacements qui
est un axe Ford de en faveur de la
sobriété pour effectivement limiter les
RE de CO2 maintenant il faudra vérifier
que ça profite bien aux usagers se
baisse de TVA et là c'est le rôle de
contrôle que nous mènerons au Sénat et
je pense que Philippe Tabarro il sera
particulièrement attentif un dernier mot
sur les finances des collectivités
puisque il y a une ligne rouge pour les
mers c'est l'encadrement des de leurs
dépenses il en a ça a été réintroduit
pardon via le 49-3 alors Christophe
béchute sur ce plateau disait qu'il
était ouvert à un dialogue avec le Sénat
est-ce qu'un compromis vous semble
possible sur cette question
d'encadrement des dépenses écoutez oui
je pense que c'est les fameux contrats
de Cahors aujourd'hui de ce qu'on
reproche pour vous c'est contradicat oui
c'est une erreur dans la méthode dans
laquelle ça a été mis en place
c'est-à-dire de mettre une contrainte je
pense qu'on peut négocier avec les
collectivités locales les élus je vous
le disais sont tous responsables ils
savent qu'ils doivent mener des budgets
en équilibre et que il faut faire des
économies pour pouvoir investir et que
l'investissement c'est l'avenir donc je
pense que cette logique là les élus
locaux nos chevilles au corps donc après
on peut négocier et on peut discuter
mais c'est jamais bon d'avoir un bâton
et une carotte et je pense que le retour
des contrats de Cahors 2 c'était du même
acabit voire pire puisque des sanctions
étaient encore plus sévères aujourd'hui
le gouvernement l'a entendu et
Christophe a ouvert des portes laissant
place à une négociation possible on
attend de voir c'est pas néanmoins pour
vous c'est oui les collectivités doivent
faire des efforts mais pas de coercition
de la part du gouvernement je pense que
c'est pas de coercition et c'est
vraiment une une négociation qui doit
avoir lieu et en tout cas c'est un
dispositif qui doit être négocié avec
les élus avec les associations
représentants des élus qui ont un poids
réel aujourd'hui et qui c'est une ligne
rouge dans le vote du budget pour vous
tout à fait merci Alex à tout à l'heure
on parlera du débat des républicains et
ce sera évidemment dans le club dans
quelques instants on va aller au Havre
retrouver Célia Caradec journaliste a
Tendance Ouest bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous Célia et on va parler
d'un autre sujet avec vous puisque c'est
aujourd'hui le lancement de la campagne
des Restos du coeur et vous avez suivi
les préparatifs oui bonjour à toutes les
deux effectivement je me suis rendue
dans un centre situé dans le quartier du
rond-point que vous connaissez Agnès
canailler quartier populaire on était à
deux pas de la gare du Havre et des
universités et la distribution débutée
des hier dans ce centre j'ai été
accueilli par Madeleine bunell la
responsable depuis 6 ans qui encadre
environ 70 bénévoles alors ce centre il
a aidé 2000 personnes l'année dernière
pendant l'hiver à peu près autant cet
été et autant vous dire qu'il s'attend à
avoir plus de monde cette année encore
pas besoin même de poser la question on
l'évoque tout de suite au micro quand on
est responsable de ce centre là-bas
Madeleine la responsable elle me dit
qu'elle accueille plus de retraités plus
de ce qu'elle appelle les petits
salariés cette des profils qu'elle voit
de plus en plus ces dernières années et
notamment pour ses inscriptions cette
année sont donc des travailleurs pauvres
qui ont des petits contrats des petites
missions d'intérim à la journée parfois
et j'ai effectivement pu le constater
dans les témoignages recueillis
notamment celui de Stéphane coiffeur de
55 ans qui peine à retrouver un emploi
il n'aurait jamais pensé pousser la
porte des restos et c'est une
conseillère sociale de son quartier qui
l'a orienté vers l'association lui qui
venait initialement chercher des
conseils pour des factures impayées
alors la responsable est plutôt inquiète
évidemment quand elle entend les
responsables de la grande distribution
évoquée une inflation à deux chiffres
pour l'année prochaine en 2023 ça ne
fait pas sourire dit-elle Agnès tout
simplement une question est-ce que le
gouvernement d'un côté les employeurs en
font eux assez pour aider ces petits
travailleurs ces petits salariés comme
elle le dit et notamment peut-être les
jeunes que vous connaissez bien puisque
vous êtes présidente la Mission Locale
du Havre oui bonjour Célia et merci
alors effectivement il y a des vrais
inquiétudes aujourd'hui sur cet enjeu du
pouvoir d'achat notamment chez les les
travailleurs faibles salaires les
étudiants aussi qui sont en difficulté
pour en ce qui concerne les jeunes
effectivement la mission locale dans
l'émission locale on a des dispositifs
aujourd'hui d'accompagnement qui sont le
contrat d'engagement jeunes qui permet à
des défis financièrement mais aussi
d'accompagner moi je crois beaucoup dans
les formules de gagnants gagnants
donnant donnant si les jeunes
s'investissent et il y a de l'emploi
aujourd'hui
il suffit d'être sur les bons métiers
les bonnes formations et d'avoir la
volonté d'accéder à ces emplois là et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à redonner
de la capacité de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat en ce qui concerne les Restos du
Coeur et la distribution alimentaire ils
sont nécessaires moi je voudrais au
passage saluer quand même l'ensemble des
bénévoles parce qu'il faut savoir que
toutes ces associations là elles
fonctionnent grâce à des hommes et des
femmes qui donnent de leur temps que ce
soit pour collecter des aliments et pour
redistribuer tous les jours durant les
campagnes d'hiver c'est vrai aussi pour
la Banque alimentaire c'est vrai pour
l'ensemble des associations qui font du
soutien alimentaire et aujourd'hui elle
va être d'autant plus
utile c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi
favoriser favoriser la transmission des
invendus pour les Restos du Coeur
transmission favoriser la donation des
citoyens pour permettre aujourd'hui les
réserves parce que c'est aussi une de
leurs fortes inquiétude parce qu'ils
vont être aussi soumis à des coûts
supplémentaires pour pouvoir assurer les
dons auprès de tous ceux qui en ont
besoin et le gouvernement fait assez
c'est aussi la question de Célia les
mesures ciblées c'est une bonne chose
c'est la bonne méthode et mesure ciblées
c'est une bonne chose je rappelle aussi
qu'il y a les fameuses primes pouvoir
d'achat qui peuvent être augmentés
jusqu'à 6000 euros donc là ça dépend
aussi de la bonne volonté des employeurs
parce qu'elles sont soumis quand même à
certains avantages fiscaux donc il faut
que les employeurs aussi mettent la main
à la pâte ça ne peut pas être que du
point de vue du gouvernement le
gouvernement incite le gouvernement met
en place des aides notamment à tout ce
qui concerne la sobriété énergétique le
coût de l'énergie des aides aussi pour
rénover les appartements ce qu'il faut
prendre aussi le problème au long terme
mais je pense que c'est un enjeu
collectif et c'est un enjeu de société
merci Agnès merci beaucoup
notre invité on remercie Célia Karadec
évidemment qui était chez vous au HAVRE
merci Célia d'avoir été avec nous dans
20 minutes dans le club des territoires
on va parler du débat entre les trois
candidats à la présidence DLR les lignes
se sont affirmées hier soir y a-t-il en
vainqueur on verra ça dans 20 minutes
merci nescalier merci d'avoir été avec
nous et c'est Christian Estrosi qui va
nous rejoindre à votre place c'est parti
bonne journée au revoir